hello everyone and a special what's up
to all you doctors out there
welcome back to the show that today will
become a full-on hybrid hair
hoot nanny i'm your human host mark
ellis and it's my job to escort you
through the loony hijinks of toontown
and the rest of planet earth whose very
fate might be at stake
in this cartoon crossover cavalcade
space jam
versus who framed roger rabbit in one
corner we have the revolutionary big
screen rabbit known as
roger to his pals and raja to bob
hoskins
in the other it's the bunny who started
it all alongside another mythological
figure who's
usually posing with the n orange prop
michael jordan
air jordan hair jordan and the rest of
the looney tunes are taking on roger
jessica and all the cigar shopping
babies you can ask for
here's how we'll determine a winner
round one box office
round two tomato meter slash audience
score
round three characters round four
cultural
impact and then we'll do a wild card
round that could just be road runner
battling the coyotes from who framed
roger with their hyenas
okay well roadrunner is going to battle
some hyenas the winner of today's match
might get a shout out somewhere in the
next 10 episodes of the last dance
the loser
it's okay i talked to the judge and he
agreed to drop the sentencing down to a
dropped piano on the head
apologies to anyone in the valiant
family watching today for everyone else
it's time for the opening tip
now roger is his name laughter is his
pain
come on you dope and tires bro but watch
him go insane
round one box office since motion
pictures became less time consuming than
learning how to read
talky starring human beings tend to do
well at the cineplex
movies featuring animated characters are
even more of a buck churner and when you
put live action and animation together
you get boffo box office sorry not you
cool world but most other people when
who framed roger rabbit was released in
theaters in the summer of 1988
it became the must-see phenomenon of the
year so much so that it ended up
grossing 154 million dollars in domestic
receipts
which equals 344 million in today money
that's got to be the highest grossing
film that year right uh
oh time for wapner rain man the film
that sunk
kmart stock and won best picture was the
only flick to best roger at the cinemas
mr rabbit and his lovely wife ushered in
a fresh new perspective on animation
and the revolutionary technology that
married human actors with their tuned
counterparts
inspired a new wave of affection for
hand-drawn characters
including some of roger's predecessors
like a duck
a mouse a martian and yes a bunny
space jam took flight eight years later
in the fall of 1996
which was conveniently just after
michael jordan led the chicago bulls to
their fourth nba title in six years
and their first since he returned from
the baseball diamond
they're both a baseball player now right
and
i'm a shakespearean actor another
long-winded sports reference from mark
is that what you said
well yes but that's also relevant
because that's basically the plot of
space jam
just replace mike's human teammates with
classic looney tunes characters
swap out the eastern conference for the
otherworldly villains known as the
monstars
add a dash of bill murray and presto
space jam
the thanksgiving hit would do 90 million
dollars in domestic business
which nets out to 187 million dollars
when we adjust for inflation
both films were also worldwide box
office success stories
as rk maroon's rabbit bested the warner
brothers bunny
with an earthly total of 354 million to
250 million
who framed roger rabbit was the bigger
hit but it was also the most expensive
film
ever made up to that point utilizing
every penny of its 70
million dollar allowance meanwhile if
you caught the last
dance you saw footage of the basketball
court slash workout complex that
warner's
built for his earnest to train during
space jam
i just hope that didn't cost 70 million
dollars because i would really like to
add one of them
onto my studio apartment i know i know
the real question everyone has is hey
mark what movie was the all-time highest
budget before roger came along
the answer you guessed it rambo
three roger would eventually see his
record fall to another muscly action
hero
some guy from the future who came back
in time to buy sunglasses and learn a
tiny bit of spanish
it's hasta lavista for space jam in this
round
as unfortunately i'm not allowed to
factor in the jordan brand's net worth
well not in this round anyway roger
rabbit gets the win
and is on the board first one to nothing
but i still got
it
[Music]
yeah you still got it round two tomato
meter slash
audience score okay so the tune squad is
down a free throw
early in the game but now they have a
chance to catch up because surely the
tomato meter will honor the legacy of
the greatest
player to uh no no being told not
critics didn't necessarily fall in love
with the jam as it sits
rotten on the tomato meter at a mere 43
percent
hey someone should do a podcast about
this traffic
maybe you call it rotten tomatoes is
wrong
so if the world's most famous baller and
earth's favorite care enthusiast
can't get the critics on their team what
chance do any other tunes have
well if you're a revolutionary like
roger rabbit the odds
are ever in your favor who framed that
guy is a certified fresh
prepare yourself 97 on the tomato meter
it's nice to have the signature style of
richard williams's creations on your
side
it's even better when they meet up with
filmmaking geniuses like steven
spielberg and director
robert zemeckis of course roger also had
a leg
or a paw i don't know what you call
bunny appendages he had a
thing up on the competition simply
because he arrived on this technological
plymouth rock
first if it makes space jam feel any
better cool world
also had to follow in the more immediate
aftermath of jessica and her hubby
and it's just four percent on the tomato
meter
roger rabbit also has an impressive
audience score landing again at fresh
with 84 percent
meanwhile space jam's audience score
does give it its first taste of fresh
as it does just stretch it out to 63
percent
so here's the bad news for space jam
fans uh your movie's not gonna win this
round either and it's down two to
nothing
who framed roger rabbit is going to take
round number two
but not before i give some verbal
gatorade to michael jordan the
documentary the last dance
is tied with roger rabbit on the tomato
meter at 97 percent
and has an audience score of 95
if you watch that documentary you know
being up two games to nothing
is a really good place to be unless
there's a certain guy named mike
on the other team i know it down oh yeah
let's hear the story i've been in this
situation many times before
we can still win this thing round three
characters
yeah that mic fella also goes by michael
jeffrey jordan aka the greatest athlete
to ever walk the face of the earth
sorry bo jackson it's true which makes
him somewhat of a compelling character
you might say
but in order to win a round based on
characters it's not going to be an
individual effort
it should be a team victory
luckily that's the entire premise of
space jam a squad of famous cartoon
characters
must defeat an otherworldly team so
villainous they call themselves the
monstars
and they even had the audacity to steal
the basketball talents
of sean bradley patrick ewing grandmama
larry johnson
and charles barkley you see kids before
he was a fun tv analyst
he actually played a sport called
basketball really really well
so much so he even dunked on godzilla
once
it's true it's what youtube's for the
lakers are looking for a big man
oh oh and we couldn't forget diminutive
wake
forest legend muggsy bogues that's not
only a who's who of great ballers
it's also a cast of memorable characters
that could rival most film franchises
don't lose that confidence but space jam
was just getting started
whereas who framed roger rabbit had to
largely create new characters for the
film
the tune squad had the luxury of placing
the most famous
animated talking animals ever into a
basketball movie
no offense mickey bugs bunny daffy duck
yosemite sam sylvester the cat pepe le
pa and i'm
told he's canceled uh foghorn leghorn
tweety bird
marvin the martian so many more and we
got low a bunny
yep we got a new looney tune lady just
for the movie which sort of makes space
jam a precursor
to loving basketball don't ever call me
doll but if it's on-screen sparks you
want the rabbits to hit up would be
roger and jessica you were magnificent
was i really better than goofy she's a
sultry nightclub vixen and he
a world famous plate smasher their
romance had more ups and downs than
well an nba playoff series this round is
going to still be a challenge for who
framed roger rabbit because we had only
just met most of these characters on the
movie poster
as we strolled into the theater but once
we got there we felt like we'd know them
our whole lives
in part because every circle of friends
has that mismatched pair that argue
like roger and jessica we've all sat
next to them at a dinner party
speaking of mismatches imagine being
handcuffed to a cartoon as
wild and as frenzied as roger or better
yet put yourself in the rabbits
comically oversized shoes
you're handcuffed to a gruff down on his
luck gum shoe named eddie valiant
oh and his brother was killed when a
toon dropped a piano on his head
a tune no who framed roger rabbit makes
a run in this round because of that
human component
bob hoskins is playing it straight and
he becomes the perfect foil for roger's
antics and joanna cassidy's dolores
seasons the proceedings with just the
right amount of spice to inspire eddie
he always is funny or only on days when
he's wanted for murder unlike the movies
here villains can team up with their
heroic counterparts in hopes to score a
point
and judge doom presents a strong case
for
best villain of the 1980s i said it and
i don't consider it a hot take
christopher lloyd was the exact right
choice to play an authoritarian figure
that hates cartoons so much
he invented his own sick formula to rid
the world of them
dip and now it's fun sidebar time
did you know that in the film dip is
described as a combination of elements
which is actually the same cocktail used
to erase
used animation cells and make them fit
to be a fresh canvas again
so in reality that stuff does actually
kill tunes well doom found the way
turpentine acetone
benzene he calls it the dip the monstars
are a fun group of evil aliens to root
against and danny devito
was the best possible iteration of swac
hammer one could hope for
and although the humans and who framed
roger rabbit blended together much more
believably than in space jam
that wasn't necessarily the goal of the
1996 beloved classic
michael jordan will never be confused
with bob hoskins as far as
acting chops or height goes obviously
but the mere fact that mj the goat of
round ball
starred in a major motion picture as he
was returning to his apex in the nba
goes beyond hey are you trained in
stanislavski's method
and if it is humanity you crave don't
worry bill murray
wayne knight and larry bird don't just
round out golf's most unique foursome
particularly murray provides a steady
diet of laughs to get all the folks who
aren't there
for looney basketball time through with
a smile on their face
what kind of camera is that it's just
would you not point that at me please
and close the lens
who framed roger rabbit deserves a ton
of credit for creating a whole new world
of remarkably lovable animated friends
and foes
charles fleischer the voice of roger and
benny the cab
and greasy and psycho deserves the
lion's share of credit for making
roger's hyper manic energy endearing
as does animation legend richard
williams but space jam
has michael jordan and the looney tunes
and bill murray
toontown put up a good fight but it's
the tune squad that takes this round and
they're on the board
it's roger 2 can you do
well you know what i mean i may not be
very tall but
i'm slow round four cultural influence
when we think about the most influential
art ever made
one can be forgiven if roger rabbit or
bugs bunny don't immediately come to
mind and sure no one's going to confuse
these two movies with heralded game
changers like citizen kane
star wars or rocky iv what
it ended the cold war i'm not making
this up watch the documentary
[Music]
but you'd be hard-pressed to find two
movies that created a more seismic shift
in filmmaking techniques and an
influence on younger generations than
who framed roger rabbit
and space jam in 1988 when we met roger
and saw him interact with eddie valiant
for the first time
it wasn't the first small step into
live-action animated crossovers
after all dick van dyke had danced with
penguins in that babysitter with
questionable tactics movie
some 20 years earlier but it was a giant
leap in terms of technological
achievement
making it look like roger and eddie were
actually playing along with one another
look no further than when they got
handcuffed together
and if it's influence on films that
scores points in this round
um how about the resurgence and animated
flicks that arose in no small part
thanks to the success of who framed
roger rabbit
disney's classic animated films had hit
somewhat of a dry spell by the 1980s but
the improved techniques and kinetic
energy
not to mention box office of roger
rabbit helped pave the way for those
early 90s classics like beauty and the
beast
aladdin and the lion king the rk maroon
tunes influence would even impact
non-disney content
such as space jam space jam owes much of
its very existence to who framed roger
rabbit
as well as the re-emergence of the
looney tunes characters into the public
consciousness in the early 1990s
but once space jam finally hit theaters
after a mad dash to get it completed on
time
which get this included 18 different
studio houses
all collaborating on the film it spawned
a legacy
that could even rival that of its
protagonist michael jordan
you could not have found a better star
athlete or more perfect timing to have
this movie come out
jordan had resubmitted his place on top
of basketball olympus
and now kids who may not have stayed up
to watch his nba heroics could get an
up-close look at mike interacting with
their favorite cartoons
[Music]
space jam ushered in a new era of
athletes crossing over from the gridiron
court or diamond
to the world of entertainment once again
michael jordan paving the way and
setting a standard for all players to
try to live up to
lebron james kevin durant jimmy butler
and more have all found
success in front of the camera on the
big screen in addition to their on-court
prowess and all of them have credited
space jam with having a huge influence
on their careers
and even for stars who'd rather stick to
round ball virtually every modern nba
player
first got to see mj not in a game or
even a gatorade ad but when he saved the
world from the monstars in space jam
the jordan brand has become one of the
most profitable and identifiable
corporate entities in the world
so much so that critics might point to
space jam as nothing more than a
90-minute nike commercial
cool shoes in fact director joe pitka
actually did direct two hair jordan ads
in the early 90s
as well as the nothing but net ads where
magic and larry are having a shooting
contest for big macs
now why two multi-millionaires can't
just buy their own two dollar sandwich
beats me
but that's the beauty of competition
listen it's a man's game
and you can't play if space jam was just
an ad for mike and the looney tunes
it did the trick to date space jam has
racked up an astonishing
1.2 billion dollars in merchandising
sales
and at last count featured 78 product
tie-ins
70 of which are owned by yours truly
economists now gauge the total financial
impact of that movie to be
okay i need you to sit down again
between four to six
billion bucks the movie did well at
theaters but that's some dr
evil chatter right there also have
noticed the space jam soundtrack which
featured a combo of jock jams and r b
tunes no no not that kind of tune the
music version of
tune that had become synonymous with
bugs mike daffy and the gang
winning the most important sporting
event in the history of recorded time
from a cinematic standpoint who framed
roger rabbit is by far the more
influential motion picture
its countless innovations and
advancements reinvigorated the stale
state of animation
and it gave another feather in the cap
of back to the future director robert
zemeckis who would go on to add films
like
forrest gump what lies beneath and
flight to his resume
but since its release in 1996 space jam
has become a cultural touchstone in the
world of sports
music and animation in terms of michael
jordan's career
who framed roger rabbit might be when
jordan established himself as the best
basketball player on earth
but space jam is when the rest of the
planets aligned
to start winning championships space jam
wins the round
and all of a sudden we're tied at two
apiece
[Music]
and now it's time for the wild card
round re-watchability
you just gotta wonder who framed roger
rabbit is feeling a bit like the utah
jazz right now
you had jordan on the edge of
elimination but now
he's tied the game and the ball is in
his hands and upon rewatching space jam
it still holds up in terms of comedy
thank you bill murray
perhaps i could be of some assistance
and
seeing our favorite animated characters
in their prime thank you looney tunes
well that's how it goes it's also just
plain fun to see mj
you know have a good time for years the
bulk of our michael jordan experience
was seeing his laser-like
intensity and near psychopathic
competitive drive on the court
for every fun haynes underwear ad there
were full playoff series that saw him
endure double and even triple teams
not to mention the jordan rules and in
context of where he was
in his career the mj in space jam was
truly at a crossroads coming back from
baseball
after being humbled by a younger
friskier orlando magic team
featuring fellow movie star shaq in the
previous year's playoffs just think
about the confidence mj must have had in
order to agree to do a movie
where he returns from baseball to play
basketball and win it all
before he was able to do that same feat
in real life
that's the michael we get to witness in
space jam and for what it's worth
he's pretty damn charismatic in his
first starring role the scene that still
gets me is when he's golfing with his
buddies
we get a look into jordan in his other
natural element
having fun and talking trash with bill
murray wayne knight and larry legend
it's a fun conduit into the looney tunes
universe and from there
it's really on our animated pals to
drive the movie home
who framed roger rabbit may not have any
human stars that will command a
10-part documentary series but that was
never the point
this wasn't a movie looking to prop up a
superstar or sell a ton of fast food
product tie-ins
it was a true marriage of live action
and animation inside a film noir
detective shell
that just happened to appeal to everyone
and i'm happy to report
it still holds up as just that great
who framed roger rabbit is legendary the
mood feels like old-timey hollywood
through a fun-house mirror
and luckily the movie doesn't need to
slow to a crawl to explain that
this is an alternate universe where
tunes exist as real characters
humans don't necessarily get along with
them all that well but that becomes the
charm of the film itself
eddie and roger forced to work together
against a villainous presence that
isn't all he appears to be holy smoke
he's a tomb
surprise whatever the artistic goal of
space jam might have been
its crowning achievement will always be
its nostalgic quality
and when memories of a simpler time are
on demand like that it warrants not only
love and respect
but a sequel here's a fun prop bet will
michael jordan show up for a cameo in
space jam 2
starring lebron james a few years ago i
would have said
no not in a hundred million years no
matter how cold it gets in satan's foyer
but now i'm thinking there's a shot i am
looking forward to space jam too
there's more stories we can tell with a
new generation of great athletes
and our favorite characters on the big
screen but if it comes down to only
revisiting either space jam or who
framed roger rabbit on my tv
it's the story acting and sheer comic
energy
of who framed roger rabbit i'll flip to
space jam during commercials
and yes i'll probably be lounging in my
toon squad jersey and my jordans that
day
space jam is a fun stroll down memory
lane who framed roger rabbit is a true
cinematic landmark that utilizes its new
technology
not to show it off but as inventive
means with which we can tell a story
that can be enjoyed by the entire family
it's a close contest here
but michael jordan finally takes a loss
no one tell him that please please i
don't want to meet him and then it's
awkward one day
who framed roger rabbit wins the round
and thus the match
three to two my buddy if i will put your
fees but when i'm done he'll need no gun
to the joker he will be
in this episode i'm what you might call
a tweener i was a little too young to
fully appreciate roger rabbit though i
did love his plate smashing antics
and i could have been a smidgen too old
to be deeply influenced by space jam
although at the time looney tunes did
represent about 70
of my wardrobe it has been a treat to
celebrate both milestones in any
youngster's life here today
and now i ask you which movie had the
greater impact on your life
hit me up online at mark ellis live or
at any of rotten tomatoes social media
channel
until next time i am mark ellis
reminding each and every one out there
you the duck
you